non mais franchement là c'est
l'incartade de trop ça a beau sans doute
être un artiste qui a eu à un moment du
talent j'en sais rien mais là ce qu'il a
fait je suis normalement pas solidaire à
je la ramène au visage si vous allez
devenir parce que ce qu'il a fait c'est
innommable
il s'est moqué de jacques chirac juste
après son décès en publiant sur son
compte en aggrave une photo avec un
message abjecte et ça on n'a pas le
droit on peut penser ce qu'on veut mais
on n'a pas le droit publiquement de dire
les choses comme ça non mais je ne veux
même pas lire les mots qu'il a écrit
parce que pour moi
là on est on est dans le manque de
respect mais à la france toute entière
et j'ai été extrêmement choqué
honnêtement je trouve que là il a
dépassé les bornes
je comprends pas ce qu'ils cherchent
avec plus à comprendre il fait n'importe
quoi il est insolent il
ils parlent mal aux femmes il respecte
pas les femmes ils respectent pas un
président de la république dire c'est
une honte ce gala moi je suis à deux
doigts de l'ascension en fait sur
instagram il devrait supprimer un truc
pareil c'est un personnage en public il
ne peut pas manquer respect à ce point
là un président et donner cet exemple
c'est dégueulasse ça a été supprimé il
l'a remis sur instagram donc il ya eu un
travail de fait par passer bien bâti
charge du bez et c'est quoi l'intérêt en
fait de tout le temps provoquer
provoquer que ce soit dans des nappes
coussins pour exister
heureusement les médias lui labour une
grosse tribune